début je pense que nos collègues aussi
ont des questions
à poser je voudrais savoir quelles sont
les différentes entités qui composent
mackinsey en france
et parmi elles le rôle de celle qui est
domicilié dans l'état du delaware aux
états unis donc une réponse précise à
une question précise
auprès de quelle identité en france ou
ailleurs sont domiciliés les contrats de
travail des de vos collaborateurs
travaillant en france votre chiffre
d'affaires et vos bénéfices réalisés en
france et dernière question pour cette
première salve qu'elle est l'entité de
mckinsey qui porte le chiffre d'affaires
réalisé en secteur public en france et
pourquoi le mckinsey & company france
donc ne publie pas ses comptes annuels
merci pour vos réponses
sauf s'il ya une autre salve de noms
madame madame les reportages et répondre
à vos questions je rappelle que
l'interdît en tant que responsable du
pôle secteur public et pas en tant que
directeur général de mckinsey france je
le précise ce pont
jeu donc nous travail maclean's et
france est enregistrée auprès du
registre du registre des sociétés
l'ensemble des contrats de travail est
porté par cette société de droit
français et l'ensemble deux chiffres du
chiffre d'affaires est porté par cette
société doha français l'élément que vous
mentionnez c'est que nous sommes
organisés en forme de succursales voilà
rapportant à l'entité mère qui est basé
au delaware mais l'ensemble de nos
activités secteur public secteur privé
et lens ont des contrats de travail sont
portés par cette société de droit
français
ce que ça signifie que vous êtes soumis
aux impôts français comme là pour bien
sûr s'il était bien sûr monsieur le
président merci
et je le dis très nettement nous payons
l'impôt sur les sociétés en france et
l'ensemble des salariés qui travaillent
dans une cité droit français qui paie
ses impôts en france
[Musique]